una semana de negociaciones entre la
francia insumisa y el partido socialista
con resultados hasta anoche y conocidos
tras el anuncio del diputado adrián cap
nos de esta mañana
existe un principio de acuerdo entre
delegaciones corresponde al partido
socialista validar los
concesionarios socialista y jugadores
de uno y ese es el problema del partido
socialista la dinámica para unirse a la
coalición de izquierdas de cara a las
elecciones legislativas genera mucha
polémica interna y
político nos han juntado visión de wawel
este partido de gobierno que ha dominado
la vida política durante 50 años corre
el riesgo de fracturarse dividiéndose en
tres los que seguirán con macrón los que
se irán por su cuenta y los que se
sumarán al acuerdo
sin fondo dijo lipsic y si foxit irak o
en efecto muchos militantes temen perder
las responsabilidades locales que aún
están en manos de los socialistas algo
figuras del partido como el exministro
de interior
bernat carnet amenazan con abandonarlo
alegando ideas políticas incompatibles
con la francia insumisa para todos
aquellos que van a hacer candidatos de
todos modos porque no aceptan este
acuerdo tenemos que hacer esta campaña
según el acuerdo con la francia e
insumisa unos 70 socialistas serían
investidos para las elecciones
legislativas es decir mucha más
representación que la lograda con el
resultado de anne hidalgo en las
elecciones presidenciales internamente
los negociadores socialistas habrían
aceptado buena parte del programa común
aunque la cuestión de la desobediencia a
las normas europeas sigue como un
importante punto de divergencia